all right let's stick with the Kerry
Lake stuff for a little bit longer Kerry
Lake lost in Arizona she wanted to be
the governor more people voted for her
opponent Katie Hobbs and Katie Hobbs
will be the governor a couple days ago
um Carrie Lake
put out a statement
saying we have a lawsuit and the lawsuit
is going to stop certification
it did not stop certification so now
Kerry lake has
another lawsuit
another lawsuit and this one is now that
the election is certified it was a bogus
certification so she has a different new
lawsuit let's listen Arizona is at the
tip of the spear and we just had an
election here November 8th which was run
like they run elections in banana
republics and this is why I'm going to
be contesting the election as you saw
earlier this week some of the um I call
them clowns running our circus of
Elections actually certified the
election my opponent Katie Hobbs who
should have recused herself but oversaw
the election in a very shady and shoddy
way actually certified the election and
a lot of America First Patriots were
saying Carrie what are you doing why
aren't you contesting this what's wrong
and what they don't realize is that in
order to contest an election in Arizona
it has to be certified so this sham
election had to be certified for us to
begin contesting it and we will be
contesting it we're going to be filing
our lawsuit on Friday and I'll be
filling you in more later on in this
program about the lawsuit and what's
coming up yes Friday Friday she's going
to very very powerfully inform us about
that so A couple different things number
one earlier in the week she didn't
mention by the way in order to contest
that it needs to be certified the
lawsuit earlier in the week was to
prevent the certification so let's take
a look at that just as a reminder
how possibly can a republican attorney
general sit there and a governor sit
there and allow this Fiasco people in
Arizona have to understand some
Independence and Democrats you look like
idiots on the world stage this looks
like something that would happen in the
worst of banana Republic's Cary Lake
yeah I mean the Optics and just a little
over an hour the Optics of them um
sitting there and signing their
signature can you imagine to this sham
election they did it back in 2020 two
years ago and many of us gasped and said
how could they do this why couldn't they
give more time to look into all of the
issues now fast forward 2022 today and
we've got more issues than we saw in
2020 in that sham election we have just
a blatant sabotaging of election day a
disrespect a disregarded
disenfranchisement of election day
voters that's a lot of words and if they
sit there and sign their names to this
sham Certification history will never
forgive them they will go down as as
three of the very worst in history
yeah so then she went on to explain they
have a lawsuit um so that lawsuit failed
the certification took place a few hours
later now the next lawsuit is to
decertify which of course is not
actually a thing uh this will just go on
and on and then the next layer to this
carry Lake thing is the god layer let's
talk about that next before you go if
you enjoyed this video and want to see
more please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David Pacman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description